there's sex stuff and then there's weird
sex stuff and then there is whatever the
Washington Post is writing about in this
article Washington Post publishing a
leather mask of a donkey with chains and
spikes and stuff and a leather mask of
an elephant and it says in the world of
sexual fetishes crossing the political
aisle is a
kink does a forced vote for The Other
Side get your pulse racing there is a
dominatrix for that guys who want their
sexual partners to make them vote for
the opposite party guys who are and this
is I assumed this was a fake thing no
The Washington Post details in in lurid
detail all these different groups online
and on various sex social media sites
thousands of people joining these groups
to say yeah I'm a liberal but I want a
republican to just call me a dumb idiot
leftist